QUIM GIL: My name is Quim Gil.
I work with Wikimedia foundation
as technical contributor
coordinator.
Wikimedia is the movement that
develops Wikipedia, but also
many other projects like
Wikimedia commons, Wiktionary,
Wikiquote, Wikidata,
and so forth.
We care about free knowledge,
spreading free knowledge
for everybody.
We are definitely one of
the largest repositories
of knowledge of
the world, and that
requires plenty of
open source projects.
So yes, we run a lot of
software in the back end.
This year's Summer of
Code was very special,
because we went from
nine students to 19.
And that was great.
But at the same time
we were a bit scared.
Can we handle that?
But the results
were pretty amazing.
So we are really happy
about the experience.
And also, we are very happy
about the small detail, which
is important, which is seven
of those students were women,
which was a very
different scenario
than any previous years.
So when you do this big
jump, basically doubling
the number of projects
that you are taking,
you really need to get
organized in a different way.
You need to be more systematic.
You need to rely on a lot more
on the mentors themselves.
Each theme must be
more autonomous.
But we kind of manage.
We set this rule
that every project
needed to have two
mentors, for instance.
They turn out to
work pretty well.
We also put our bet in using
the regular community channels
for support, for deployment.
In this way, just
after a few weeks,
our Summer of Code students were
not Summer of Code students.
They were just regular members
of our community using exactly
the same channels as
the rest of us used.
There's so much work to do.
We could have Summer
of Code every season
if we could just handle that.
What we're interested
in promoting more
in future additions is, well,
everybody knows Wikipedia.
And, of course, Wikipedia
is our champion project.
But precisely because
of that reason,
we get a lot of attention
from the Wikimedia foundation,
but also from many contributors.
We have many other projects
that are just as important.
As I said before, like Wikimedia
commons, or Wikivoyage,
they are quite specialized and
they also have software needs.
We want to help them more.
We helped them
already in this round.
But we really want
mentors and students
to put their focus on
these other projects.
Because they need a lot of love,
and they have great communities
that would help
anybody stepping in.
If you want to see something
improve in Wikipedia, if you're
missing something that
should be there, all we do
is open source.
And actually for us,
code is also text
that anybody can edit.
Step in.
I think we are a
great community.
We are really friendly.
And actually, any little
change that you can contribute
is going to be seen and
used by millions, literally.
The core software
that runs Wikipedia
is developed with PHP.
And this is the main language
we use for many projects.
However, we have
many opportunities
for JavaScript
projects in the form
of plug-ins that could
be used for improved
musical notation, for instance.
Or improve math syntax.
Or you can also help,
like helping Wikimedia
support better media formats.
It is all about
increasing the diversity
of free content, free media that
Wikipedia users could just use.
Go check mediawiki.org.
This is the mediawiki.org.
This is the site
where we coordinate
all our technical activities.
We have a page called
how to contribute,
which describes the
many different areas.
Because, really, we have
from JavaScript gadgets
that someone could
code on a weekend
to deep pieces of infrastructure
that are running our servers.
I mean, in between you have
many different projects for
designers, testers,
documentation.
We have about 500
regular contributors
and about 2,000
contributors in total.
And there's really hundreds
of software projects there.
There's a chance for almost
any type of free software
contribution.
We have former students
that are in the community.
that are mentors.
We have former students that are
now employees of the Wikimedia
foundation or on other
Wikimedia organizations.
This year, we had
a student that,
right after the
evaluation, was already
starting to work as
full-time developer
in the project she
was working on.
Yes, we are not participating
in Summer of Code
for-- to hire developers.
But of course, it's
a possible path.
And well, it shows
the possibilities
that great students might
have in our community.
MALE SPEAKER: Great, all right.
That sounds great.
QUIM GIL: Good.